what's what's the next door we have this
is the George Lucas reportedly down to
return to Star Wars but wants full
control yeah here it is George Lucas one
star was bang wanted back you're not
getting it he's not getting it there's
no way
maybe there's I haven't seen the last
one I'm kind of oh dude we're gonna rag
on Star Wars right now I can't I really
want to see the no you don't know you
don't I don't I do it's sad man it's is
it sad as it like no like what happened
or was it said or really yeah you saw
the last Jedi I saw the last Jedi that's
the second one of the last three right
I'm not gonna prompt you what did you
think about it well I know I already
talked about it a little bit I'm waiting
to get mad I liked it no all right well
let's read a little bit more I want to
know if people liked it or not
did you guys they're gonna say it
everyone's gonna say they hate it but
there's a delay on the super chance all
right Wow
I thought it was good now you will be at
that's because you're wrong well let's
see what's going on with George Lucas
ooh there's no secret that George Lucas
hasn't always been the biggest fan of
what Disney's done with their Star Wars
sequel trilogy in fact the studio's ever
even been pretty open about the fact
that the filmmaker was vocally opposed
to their approach to the beloved sci-fi
franchise in his book the the ride of a
lifetime lessons learned from 15 years
as CEO the Walt Disney Company for
instance Bob Iger explains that Lucas
felt there was weren't enough visual or
technical leaps forward in JJ Abrams the
force awakens not only that but Lucas
was also notably absent from the
premiere of the rise of Skywalker and
while you can be certain certainly
understand why he's taken issue with
some of the recent movies it seems both
parties are hoping to soon get back in
bed together hmm that's one way to put
it yeah that's interesting it's like why
see I don't see Disney ever ever letting
me
first of all they beat the thing to
death they're gonna keep beating it and
no and now they're like we're not losing
our money how much we spent on this yeah
well how much was it the deal I don't
know billions well actually they might
they might say so let's do this let's
can I not okay
let's I can actually read it because I
can use the studio to actually read it
so it says you got it yeah a few weeks
ago we told you that Lucasfilm wants
George to return and help out with the
franchise in more of an official
capacity following his assistance with
the aforementioned rise which was done
more as a favor to JJ than anything else
and while still unclear if it'll happen
we've now received another update in the
situation so this is coming from we got
this covered calm they say where were
they just say according to sources close
to we got this covered the same ones who
informed us that Oh spoilers would die
in the rise of Skywalker alright well
we'll just leave there and that spoilers
would be revealed as a traitor in the
film they're not gonna name it so fine
whatever
good cuz I haven't seen it in months
before the movie at theaters
Lucas has said he'll return but only if
he has full creative control over the
next franchise from what we're told he
thinks the studio has made a mess of it
and fee and feels he needs a great
amount of control to get back not only
that but he also wants to bring along
Dave Filoni responsible for the Clone
Wars and Star Wars rebels okay that's a
good call that's a good call those
series were yeah I mean I didn't want to
hear good things about that I don't
watch a whole lot of Clone Wars actually
you're bad things about rebels I don't
know though I don't know rebels but the
Clone Wars I hear is a really good show
yeah yeah definitely
they say want to bring him back with him
to help turn things around with the idea
being to have the fan favorite act as
George George's right-hand man that all
being said our sources who also revealed
the big pal between Palpatine twist in
rise way back in September say there's
some resistance from Disney in regards
to George proposal and understandably so
after all Kathleen Kennedy is still the
boss over at Lucasfilm
that's a huge mistake I'm saying that
for now at least and while they would
love to have Lucas involved again they
want him as more of an adviser
consultant it'd still be an official
role and he'd be very involved in future
projects but they're not willing to give
full creative control at this time and
that's where things stand for now if we
had to guess George Lucas will
eventually make his way
back to Star Wars but in what capacity
remains to be seen with Kennedy very
likely on her way out though and Marvel
Studios Kevin Feige also said to be
interested in taking over the sci-fi
property you can expect some major
changes for the brand in the next few
years I figured out what's wrong with
Star Wars what is it
all right first of all there was this
really great meme on reddit I think it
was from Lord of the Ring memes do you
know Lord of the Ring memes no like if
you browse all on reddit you'll see a
ton of like Star Wars memes Lord of the
Ring memes and there's when it said
imagine Lord of the Rings was sold to
Disney and the producer said we're going
to retcon and basically erase the Hobbit
the Zimmer iliyan and all of the other
you know junior Tolkien you know
properties yeah and we're only gonna
have it be about the original you know
Fellowship of the Ring two towers and
and Return of the King
yeah and then we're gonna expand from
those stories and ignore everything else
and then they they killed off Bilbo and
Frodo and they added in some like weird
new characters you probably be upset
yeah I think so but I figured it out I
figured out exactly what the problem of
Star Wars is there's no there's no
there's no structure like there's no
functioning continuity like they're kind
of is mm-hmm
but they it's it's not just like listen
you don't really bothered me about what
they started doing with Star Trek you
were you a big fan of Star Trek yeah so
after I think was it like Deep Space
nine mm-hmm all of a sudden I start
doing seek prequels well what like
Enterprise enterprise
I'd like to enterprise it was pretty
good it wasn't bad I liked it okay but
then they did what can I find reprised
was it was it discovery I don't know if
there's yeah I don't think there's
something between yeah discuss another
prequel the new one yeah it's another
it's another prequel so that takes place
I think those you're right it's another
prequel know their prequel yeah and so
I'm getting angry so now they did Picard
I haven't watched it and I've seen I've
actually heard bad things
oh really I'm worried yeah that sucks we
can talk about what good we'll talk
about that we'll get to that after we
talk about what's wrong with Star Wars
oh yeah go I don't I don't know where
and I don't know what any of these
movies I did with anything like when you
watch the Marvel Cinematic Universe
mm-hmm when you read the comics there's
there's somewhat of a Conte
yeah now like Marvel Comics and like DC
comics in general have been around for
so long mm-hmm things started to get
messed up and confusing yeah because
there's just too much writing going on
right but at least in the MCU
there have been continuity errors but
for the most part there's a general flow
is a you've seen the movies then you'll
understand certain things yeah and so it
feels like every time you see a new
movie you're something's being added to
the story that you understand right when
I watch the new Star Wars movie I'm like
what is this nothing makes sense anymore
hmm yeah I don't want to spoil things
for you haven't seen that the last one
yet you know I haven't
I really force awakens yeah that's okay
see plus it was basically a
shot-for-shot remake of a new hope yeah
yeah well that's okay that's okay it's
okay if they wanted to establish this in
a new way with new characters and rise
the last Jedi yeah I think Rian Johnson
was intentionally trying to destroy Star
Wars I think was on purpose
hmm dude and you would agree with me if
you saw the last movie really you saw
the last Jedi yeah he killed the main
antagonist there's nothing left
you win bad guys dead so what's what is
it what's what there's nothing there
well isn't and then he becomes the main
bad guy though I'm gonna have to spoil
stuff for you oh man don't spoil there's
no bad guy no there I'm not gonna this
is not a spoiler well I'm gonna tell you
yeah Palpatine is the bad guy okay
there's our ting the commercials yeah
does it make sense doesn't make sense
yeah so the they brought back Palpatine
because Rian Johnson basically ruined
the plans yeah I don't know what
happened where JJ left but then I look I
started looking at like Mandalorian I
hear it's good it's good I'm not gonna
watch it no I'm not gonna watch it you
know why it's the prequel it's a prequel
oh man great none of these stories have
anything to do with the development a
character development story development
character development development to the
Jedi anything it's like it's just it's
just all they're doing is making a
sci-fi and slapping a brand on it and
being like it's Star Wars you know what
I would want to see I would want to see
a show about the gray Jedi
do you know what the gray Jedi are they
got rid of all that stuff it's all gone
really yeah doesn't he just got rid of
it all yes
so the lore of Star Wars is gone gone
the extended universe was wiped out
because Disney was like we're better
imagine if when when like Disney
acquired Marvel they're like you know
all those comics
yeah we're getting rid of those no more
comment the movies are now the only
Canon wrong look I get it the original
Star Wars was the original Star Wars
yeah but there was so much created in
the extended universe like hey did you
ever play Knights of the Old Republic a
little bit I know the game is so good
yeah it was a long time ago it's like an
RPG and you could be like light or dark
mm-hmm awesome yeah
I packed ahead of its time yeah man all
that stuff The Old Republic I don't even
know if it exists anymore
like like I bet people still play that
game well there's so there's the there
is there's the MMO which apparently is
still can and I guess that it's called I
think it's what the Old Republic the
Star Wars The Old Republic is that what
the new one the MMO let people play like
a clown of Warcraft I'm not sure but you
know what man I liked rogue one and I
was okay like - rogue one - yeah here's
the thing the prequel the the prequels
like the legit prequels with qui-gon
jinn and obi-wan I actually liked them I
didn't think they I'm sorry say that
again
I actually like him really you didn't
like him episode one two and three one I
thought was corny and I'm like whatever
popcorn flick - was C+ you know if it
was on TV I'd watch it Revenge of the
system I do like and I would rewatch you
know I think a lot of the the dialogue
was corny yeah I think they're not like
the best movies in the world or anything
you know sequel trilogies are trash
gutter trash throw the trash and they
did so much wrong it was really funny -
because I you know I can't stand more
than anything mm-hmm
fakeness be honest with me yeah but they
can't do it was all about money so when
Mark Hamill start doing the press tour
for you know the last Jedi yeah he was
miserable was it like you can see the
clips where he's like I can't believe
they would do this to me and then later
on he's like I really like the movie you
don't we know it
you hated it you hated it but well they
turn to Luke Skywalker into a whiny baby
who gave up on it like it's you know you
know man I
the idea subvert expectations that's
what Ryan Johnson want to do I really
think you tried to destroy it on purpose
but I don't even blame Ryan Johnson for
the most part I think you ruined the
sequels but the bigger problem is that
every single time something comes out it
takes place at a random point in time in
the Star Wars universe
yeah there's no development nothing's
happening I don't know what's going on
mm-hmm and then all of a sudden it's
like here's a random plot point from 75
years before this thing happened and I'm
like well I care yeah who cares but
there's no where's that where's the
story development yeah maybe that's just
me maybe I'm biased but I start doing
the same thing with with Star Trek so
like we're the next generation well did
you like the new movies yes I like yeah
also but that's really the new movies
were complicated because there was like
a dispute over property rights and
merchandising rights and so they created
a separate timeline I think that's what
they did it they did it like well though
it wasn't I wasn't cheesy Lee done they
like did it in a way that it's pretty
cool it was it was much more like the
original series than the next generation
okay it was more action-packed so
actually I you know not necessarily true
because the original series did have a
lot of low budget like philosophical you
know technological stuff mm-hmm but the
next generation was was was episodic and
it was kind of like each episode not
every episode but many episodes would
act would ask a philosophical question
based you know with with like this
platform where they could explore all
these different planets and so it was
like you go to one planet where was
ruled by women like what would things be
like and that's no way to do they can
explore these ideas and the show was
decently progressive like they didn't
want episode about you know was was data
a real life form mm-hmm or was he just
property right and they have a trial
about it was called like the make of a
man or something like that yeah amazing
yeah there was one episode where data
asks Picard about terrorism and he was
like if terrorism is so bad how come
throughout history it's worked and
Picard's like that's a good question you
know we struggle with it every day yeah
but he says I don't subscribe to the
belief that political power is derived
from the barrel of a gun so it was a
very profound show and then they did you
know Deep Space nine and they did
Voyager Voyager these
kind of carried on and and kept the
story moving and then it ended with the
Dominion War and then prequel and then
we got prequel and then we got movies
and everyone's like the movies are back
and then they're like alternate timeline
alternate oh yeah so now what I'm
hearing about the card is that it's like
job Patrick Stewart said it's a response
to trump and brexit seriously
yeah it's about like a refugee crisis or
something so like in the alternate
timeline reality they said something
like Romulus exploded the problem with
that is that in the movies Spock is like
hundreds of years from now you know
Romulus will explode or whatever will go
supernova right it's under our will so
then what happened in the Picard show
where it's like 50 years later something
happened like I don't understand what's
going on I don't watch it though I don't
I want to be fair I didn't watch it
because I just kind of feel like you
know I don't know like it's not the same
thing they're slapping Star Trek brand
on a different show about different
things and they're trying to make it
overly political to so I'm just at this
point I don't know what let me let me
we'll wrap up this sci-fi talk segment I
just think I think what these companies
are doing is they're bringing on people
who aren't fans who don't know the lore
and I look at Warcraft for instance and
like I look at the job requirements for
their lore writers and it's like be a
fan know our lore that's pretty
important right could you imagine if
Warcraft like you know brought somebody
on to write for them and they had no
idea I need the characters characters
were so they were like most people I
don't know how many people know anything
about Warcraft but they're like and then
Jaina Proudmoore
did pulled her axe from the tree and
jumped 20 feet and yelled for the Horde
people would be like Jaina is a mage for
the Alliance and wouldn't have an accent
what are you talking about it makes no
sense right all right that's what I feel
like it's happening it's like somebody's
got a writing job because their friend
was like hey you want to write you could
write like yeah what's Star Wars I don't
know I'll figure it out all right write
a story but I really do think I'll end
with this
I think JJ Abrams did it on purpose cuz
cuz kylo says let the past die kill it
if you have to
so now George is like no no don't let it
die
back give it back to you know it'd be
really funny on control I would love to
see you like George Lucas like like a
skit where he's clawing at like you know
Disney going like my precious trying to
like yeah now you gave it up buddy
gone you did the money was worth it
you